peu
[Musique]
au nord
ce décor
[Musique]
c'était la chambre
le ciel
c'était lent
[Musique]
les hommes
nos fenêtres redonner sur des fenêtres
semblables et la pluie mouille et
mocquard tard
mais mon père entre avait les yeux si
bleus que je croyais voir le ciel bleu
j'apprenais mais le son la joue contre
son bras
je crois qu'il est fier de moi il était
généreux comme ce pays et je lui dois ce
que je suis au
c'est fait
[Musique]
c'est le
chaud
monsieur
ceux des lois
[Musique]
m
et c'était mon enfance et l est est
heureuse dans la but aider les suiveurs
du javel et périls à défaut de montagne
vent je voyais la campagne 1
des gueules noires comme les tests ses
parents sa mère avait des choses
au plan
il c'était de la fausse monnaie d'un
pays
je sais qui je suis aux anges
c'était
[Musique]
m
c'était le
chambre
ce voeu
le soir
[Musique]
il y avait à la mairie le jour de la
course
une photo de jean jaurès et chaque verre
de vin était un diamant rose posée sur
fond de silicose
il parlait de 36 et des coups de grisou
des accidents défend d'être
il serait leur métier quand même hein
c'est avec eux que j'ai compris on
c'était
[Musique]
c'était le
c'est m
or
il
le ciel
selon
[Musique]
est mineur de fond
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]